buongiorno sonorità manfredini il
piacere di conoscerla si sia sono le
mamme di carlo alberto si scusi ritardo
ma ero a fare la mia seduta settimanale
di crioterapia sa per mantere che su di
giovani e carlo alberti un bambino è
estremamente fragile ma soprattutto
intelligente e l'avrà capito della sua
spiccata passione per la matematica vero
no ma non è possibile e lui non odia la
matematica scusi è che con tutti questi
figli a faccio una fatica no2 si carlo
alberto del primo matrimonio e maria
adelaide del secondo si insulta e
compagni e insegnanti strano no no
apprendi sono insufficienze beh senta
suoi 12 anni cioè diavoli del tempo per
elaborare va bene va bene lo manderemo a
ripetizioni tanto noi ce lo possiamo
permettere quindi non è un problema non
è che vuole provare il mio corso di
pilates ovviamente ho fatto io e ci
mancherebbe
io do una mano e lei è l'età non a me è
così che si fa tramite no
arrivederci